uncharted 4 is a harrowing adventure
that can take up to 18 hours to finish
rope swinging grenades and collapsing
floors come in quantity and uncharted 4
and there's always a solid amount of
swearing to follow so here's a
compilation of the many shit's craps
damn it's [ __ ] and other notable
reactions if you like more of this [ __ ]
give us a like and subscribe on YouTube
while you're there let us know your
favorite expletive Laden moment in the
series you can find me on Twitter as
normal mode thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] here we go we go here yeah
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go here we go here we go there we go
there we go here we go here we go
there we go there we go there we go here
you go
[Music]
regarding liberty [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] what an [ __ ] oh you're such
an [ __ ]
more money more problems damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it god damn god damn it damn it
damn it's that goddamn truck oh crap
holy crap holy crap holy crap holy crap
holy crap holy crap holy crap crap crap
crap don't crap holy crap
and now that they have clowns oh crap
crap
crap crap crap oh crap crap crap
better take that door hold on no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no he's my go-to guy oh no no
no no no no no no no no what said it you
gotta be kidding me
you gotta be kidding me oh you gotta be
kidding me I practically had it you can
give it another shot
[Music]
you